skateboarding was my salvation and my  way of having fun  this film is really about tony and  what's really going on inside of him  he had to reinvent skating  i've been trying to make this film for a  long time sam pitches this idea of doing  the epic tony hawk documentary  we both said yes this is amazing and  then we're off and running  it's a much deeper story and stuff that  i've never really shared at all there is  some footage in here i had no idea  existed  he is a beast who is just going to skate  no matter what  tony hawk is the reason i started  skateboarding tony hawk is just a legend  it takes a lot of dedication to do what  he does and it's really inspiring  family is hugely important to tony it  was beautiful to put that part of his  life in the film and not just make it  about skating i feel like if i'm able to  stay on my own two feet i'm gonna ride a  skateboard i'm not gonna quit doing it  [Music]  you